to alleviate all of that typing
javascript provides the keyword new
whenever we choose to use the keyword
new in front of a function indication
our function is going to run in a
special mode called constructor mode in
that mode we can expect a lot of this
work to be done for us automatically so
what is construction mode exactly
basically it's a way for your
interpreter to insert a few lines of
operations into your code because it
knows that you're gonna need them to be
done whenever you're instantiating a new
object it temporarily makes your
function run as if there was some extra
code at the beginning and end even
though you will never have typed that
code the operations it's going to insert
are basically doing the same work as the
lines you're likely to write in your own
prototypal classes so because we're
using the keyword new here we can expect
this invocation of car to run with these
extra operations inserted at the
beginning and at the end whereas here
where the keyword new does not show up
in front of the invocation of car these
lines of code would not be inserted so
in the same program we can expect this
one function to be run with and without
these inserted lines of code remember
they will never actually show up in the
code as you type it they only get run as
a result of the fact that we are using
the keyword new right before this
particular invocation now even though
I'm showing two different lines of code
one with and one without the keyword new
you would never do such a thing in your
own programs
you're gonna write functions that you
expect to be run with the keyword new or
not run with it but you would never
write a function that you may or may not
use the keyword new with the purpose of
it is to allow you to skip some of the
work you're already doing so once you
decide to use the keyword new with a
given function there's some inevitable
refactoring you're gonna have to do I've
added the keyword new to both cases and
I think it's time we delete some of the
code we don't need anymore
since we know this is how we intend to
run the function